as i understand it you
originally wanted to make a larger story
about
animal and human relations
but that changed a bit and you take us
on a journey was it similar to your
journey yeah um i
am a mother who took her kids to
seaworld
um
i am you know
i guess when i heard about the don
brancho incident in the media
i thought i read as much as i could
about it i found it um
very confusing
i kind of uh
you know thought to myself this doesn't
square sort of with you know anything
that i know about killer whales and you
know their intelligence and i just sort
of thought that they didn't
do that
to us especially in that park i sort of
thought that they you know uh are our
friends here on this planet just as
dolphins are and we have sort of these
these images of these animals and i just
it didn't make sense i wasn't sure if he
was playing and
so anyway the more i read um
and for one i also thought it was a
one-off i thought it was an aberration
and just kind of wanted to sort of
investigate what it is about us that
sort of you know
you know desires to have a relationship
with our predator counterparts
um
so i had as you suggested sort of this
bigger philosophical film in mind and um
you know i i read some and then i would
read a little bit and the more i read
the more sort of confounding it got just
because first i read that she tripped
and fell then there was this ponytail
theory
and then it sounded like it was sort of
a playful event
uh and then i read the autopsy report
and um
was uh
it's just a terrible thing to read and
to imagine and it was um became just
this
i guess i didn't want it to be
deliberate i didn't want it to be this
sort of attack
and so um from that moment and then
another kind of revelatory moment um you
know was when i found out that he'd
killed twice before
suddenly um
i realized i couldn't make the film that
i was going to be making
and uh felt um in this strange way that
i was being kind of
you know
compelled to tell uh
um the truth here um it wasn't sort of
you know
my original directive or what i had in
mind and i think that um i think a lot
of documentaries will tell you that you
just you feel compelled you sort of
can't not tell the story the former
seaworld trainers have all seen it um
i think everyone's seen it
uh by now
they uh they did some of them knew each
other some of them overlapped you know
in their tenure at sea world and some
didn't some came much much later
and um in fact we have one guy in the
film who
left seaworld not even a year ago
um so he came on very late because he
had just quit and he was still nervous
and
backed out of one interview after we'd
sort of flown out there to go interview
him he just sort of said i can't i can't
do this and then um
maybe you know two months later three
months later sort of
we revisited that
there's a quality of all that all these
people have and it's almost a
confessional quality and maybe it comes
through in the film i hope it does but
they're
my apostles i sort of refer to them as
that they have the message from the
other side but there's a lot of
guilt
and you know there isn't a confessional
aspect to this and then they sort of
needed to talk about this and and let it
go before they can kind of move on they
all have new careers now but we're never
able to really let it let go of what
happened and um felt that they abandoned
the animals
you know and the animals are very likely
doing worse and my gosh their colleagues
one of them died
so they just sort of feel like they
can't shut that door but
without kind of
talking some of this stuff through uh
you know to the extent that all
captivity is
is pro is bad or is is probably very
likely a bad thing um i always thought
that you know
um
that
you know killer whales in in sea world
were probably treated better
than like a primate in a you know
defunct zoo
so in my mind that i i was not going in
to this film
to talk about you know uh
whale
you know the state of the whales and
mistreatment of whales or anything like
that i mean this was just a complete and
i completely backed into it and then you
know
one you peel back the onion and you just
can't
you you really you know it's shocking
and in fact i really
uh you know what what shocks people a
lot is is that
um this seems so incendiary and the film
seems so incendiary but
i
it's so tip of the iceberg
i mean i just simply couldn't i
wanted the self-restraint to stick with
a single story and i wanted to sort of
tell audiences a story of tilikum start
40 years back and just march him as
through as a protagonist because i
didn't want to shoehorn all these
activist facts to overwhelm people
because i just no i don't i don't learn
that way and i don't think everybody
learns that i sort of like trust your
audience you know
i think at this point it you know i i
just have such hope i guess you know yes
i do feel that that you come out of
these films hopefully with a little bit
of shock and anger
some questions some more questions
and then ultimately hope